on the mound the 36 year old right
hander nadibal sanchez nine appearances
eight career starts against miami his
record is three and two
this will be interesting that's key boom
to turner and the nats turn a five six
three
double play in the shift
umberto again his third major league
start here's another 3-2 going again as
soto hits one high in the air right
center field brinson near the wall leaps
and he makes the catch
louis bridson makes an unbelievable
catch over the wall in center field huge
play in this ball game already got up
there
at least three feet
over the top of that wall with that
glove to make that catch kendrick at
294.
mejia ready now and the pitch kendrick
belts into right center field on the run
princeton again this one's going to be
over his head and off the wall turner
heading for third chip hales waving him
home and he will score without a play as
brinson just now playing the cam gets it
in towards second where howie kendrick
stands with his second double at his
eighth run bad at end of the year cory
dickerson the left fielder to lead off
for miami against anabol sanchez
his first pitch swinging drives going to
deep left this one way back soto at the
wall looking up and it's gone goodbye
on the first pitch of the inning corey
dickerson has tied the game with an
opposite field home run to straight away
left field
oh two coming from mejia and that one's
grounded oh rojas makes a great play
they'll get the
mickey keeps the ball in the infield
number one which likely keeps garcia
from scoring so here's trey
turner out to short and safe as rojas
did not handle it cleanly uh-oh
victor robles caught rounding third
so the nats will take the lead with
garcia scoring
and victor caught
beyond third base 2-1 after two
3-2 pitch
strike three called at the knees with a
fastball he snuck one by him
joyce obviously looking for something
off speed takes one
knee-high center of the plate
[Applause]
turner backhand short way
through a bullet to garcia
sanchez out of the inning and lonnie
ball's retired nine of his last 10 it
was adam eaton who's hit the ball
sharply twice
and there's one down the line in right
so garcia home turner screaming to third
jipao sending him no throw and now
getting back to second base is adam
eaton who delivers one of his biggest
hits of the year
4-1 nationals
[Applause]
to hopper trey turner to his left
shoulder high on the second half
that's 10 of 11 for anibal
[Applause]
trey turner
sanchez another quick inning that's 12
of his last 13.
faces loaded nobody out
down the pitch
and that one is inside ball four so a
bases loaded walk for keyboard victor
robles go back with the bases loaded
through the wickets on anderson
two more for the nats
and it's seven to one
runners at first and second still nobody
out here's trey turner sharp to the belt
here's the pitch swinging the ball slice
down the right field line long run for
sanchez he dives can't get it and it's a
fair ball going by him all the way to
the right field corner
should clear the bases two runs will
score turner's all the way to third
it'll stop there as sanchez gets the
relay in the vr
soto
skies one left field didn't know where
it was at first see if it stays in play
dickerson near that netting look out hi
goodness winner now oh and he went
through the netting oh no
there's just a little bit of a gap where
that door would swing open
and it looked like dickerson was hoping
that the netting was there and that's
the only spot where it's not
a bad day just got worse for the marlins
yeah he's coming out of the game
[Applause]
on the ground to third
that will be five for three kibum
charged it hard
and that gave garcia plenty of time to
go around the horn
sanchez two for the price of one to end
his sixth inning
wow two parts of the bat and the ball
that one's scooped up over there
honeyball sanchez just got some congrats
92 pitches 63 strikes in an outstanding
seven-inning start
so reinhardt three outs to get well
there's one more potential bright spot
if jesus sanchez can come up with his
first major league hit
there it is his first big league knock
goes down into the corner
john bernie being waved around michael a
taylor fires home not just his first hit
but also an rbi here there it is and
it's 9-3 yeah good call partner you're
absolutely right
the day where a lot of things were lost
a lot of personal victory for some of
these young marlins now here's the set
of the pitch swinging a fly ball shallow
center field and robles they're waiting
camped under it and he makes the catch
bang zuma curly w's in the books the
nationals pull away and win one easily